---
Miquella is many things. A fundamentalist.
The Unalloyed. Creator of the Haligtree, Lord
of the Eclipse, Saint Trina of the Cradlesong,
and a fearsome empyrean who has been captured,
but is unresponsive - for now.
And..after watching this video, I think you'll
agree that Miquella is a topic that almost
HAS to be explored further in some upcoming
DLC. For how could they not be? Their character
is surely too major, too foreshadowed, and
too intriguing, to just ignore.
So..let's learn everything, that there is
to know.
---
Miquella is many things. The Unalloyed. St
Trina. Twin brother to Malenia, and not just
a Demigod, but an Empyrean, who is said to
possess the very allure of a god.
And..after watching this video, I think you'll
agree that Miquella is a topic that almost
HAS to be explored further in some upcoming
DLC. For how could they not be? Their character
is too major, too foreshadowed, and too intriguing,
to just ignore.
Of course, knowing From Software, we'll probably
get DLC about the spirit jellyfish / boc / or
something instead..I don't know. So I guess
we'll just have to wait and see.
---
But until then, let's learn all there is to
know about Miquella.
For starters, Miquella is the demigod child
of Queen Marika, and King Consort Radagon..who,
as I'm sure you're well aware - are the same
being. You can learn more about the timeline
of events from my other videos, but basically
- after Radagon left Rennala - the Academy
told Radagon to go fuck himself, and Radagon
took that literally - siring a third set of
demigod children all on his own, who were
the twins Miquella, and Malenia
Which brings us to an extremely important
description - the Remembrance of the Rot Goddess,
which tells us that the twins "Miquella and
Malenia are both the children of a single
god. As such, they are both Empyreans, but
suffered afflictions from birth. Miquella
was cursed with eternal childhood, and Malenia
harbored rot within."
The Nascent Butterfly item appears to represent
Miquella, and it elaborates on his state of
eternal childhood, stating that it "appears
as if it's just emerged from its cocoon for
its entire life". Indeed, the word "Nascent"
means that something is "Just coming into
existence, and beginning to display signs
of future potential".
And I think this "eternally nascent" characteristic
is incredibly important to Miquella's character.
For Miquella and Malenia both seem to occupy
opposite sides of the life and death cycle.
That's not to say that Miquella represents
life and Malenia represents death, rather,
it seems like both land somewhere in the middle
of each process. Malenia is constantly resisting
her scarlet rot out of sheer will, and is
in this perpetual state of dying, and Miquella
is in this constant state of nascence - newly
born, and showing an abundance of life and
burgeoning potential. Special thanks to Quelaag,
for pointing this out to me.
And that word, "Abundance", is actually an
extremely key word for Miquella. For example,
there's this cut weapon, called the "Abundance
and Decay Twinblade", which symbolises the
twins, and suggests that the twins were "born
from an inseparable fate", and hold the "Runes
of both Abundance and Decay" between them.
Also, the word "abundance' shows up a lot
in the cut dialogue of a character, who I
think it's fair to assume, is Miquella. Here,
he talks about his ability to make life flourish,
stating:
"This is for thee.
Mine abundance, my drop of dew.
Quench thy thirst, throughout thy frame.
Blossom and burgeon, time and again.
Grow larger, stronger.
Until the day cometh.
When thou canst share in my dream.
Elden Ring, O Elden Ring.
Beget Order most elegant, from my tender reverie."
So again: the abundance of Miquella IS cut
content, and you shouldn't really take it
as canon - but it does give us a deeper look
- not only at the powers Miquella might have
had, but also that the world he could create.
This character goes on to say:
"If thou covetest the throne,
Impress my vision upon thine heart.
In the new world of thy making,
all things will flourish,
whether graceful, or malign."
I love that final line. "All things will flourish,
whether graceful, or malign". Miquella isn't
enforcing any notions of good or evil here
- and in the new world of his making, he simply
wants all things to flourish.
And
Miquella certainly is one of the few beings
capable of creating this "new world". That's
because he is an "Empyrean", one of the very
few who were candidates, chosen by the Two
Fingers, to succeed Queen Marika and become
a god, to usher in a new age
Now, we could go into an entire debate about
WHY the twins are valid Empyreans and WHY
they were born afflicted..but honestly, that
could be a video of its own - so for now,
I'll give the simple answer. [Source: Remembrance
of the Rot Goddess]. That is, that they were
probably valid Empyreans because they have
singular parentage from a god - but that this
singular parentage was probably also responsible
for their afflictions as well..due to the
almost..incestual implications of such a thing.
Why do I feel like George R R Martin wrote
this part..?
---
Miquella, the Fundamentalist
Anyway, let's move into the early childhood
years of..Miquella's...eternal..childhood.
Miquella's early years were clearly quite
inspired by their father, Radagon, who fostered
a bit of a fundamentalist streak in his prodigal
son. Miquella would even go on to invent fundamentalist
incantations of his own, dubbed "Discus of
Light" and "Triple Rings of Light", which
he gifted to his father.
These gifts reveal that Radagon and Miquella
had a good relationship, and they represent
those two key fundamentals of the Golden Order
- that there is a law of causality - a branching
cause and effect , but also that there is
a law of regression - that all things yearn
eternally to converge [Source: Law of Regression]
(show the discus's on screen).
In gratitude, Radagon countered with a gift
of his own - Radagon's Rings of Light. A singular
ring, , perhaps showcasing that Radagon was
all about regression, and being whole
These incantations would go on to become become
core fundamentalist spells, as they are true
to those two concepts that form the basis
of Golden Order fundamentalism
But there is another aspect of Golden Order
fundamentalism, and that is the persecution
of Those Who Live In Death. Hunters of these
undead would attempt to stamp them out with
spells such as Order's Blade and Litany of
Proper Death, which deal additional damage
against TWLID, and prevent them from resurrecting.
Put simply, Those Who Live In Death exist
because of Godwyn the Golden, one of the early
sons of Marika and Godfrey, who was killed
with a fragment of the Rune of Death, which
now spreads its undeath throughout the lands
between, via deathroot
And...there's an entire debate that we could
have here, about whether the persecution of
Those Who Live In Death is even true to the
core principles of fundamentalism. Goldmask
certainly doesn't seem to think so. In fact,
according to the "Order Healing" spell, Goldmask
lamented the hunters of Those Who Live In
Death, deeming them fanatics, who wanted nothing
more than an absolute evil to contend with.
And the reason I bring up this debate is because...you
could argue that Miquella was on the side
of these fanatics, as he created multiple
weapons that were capable of effectively slaying
Those Who Live in Death.
For example, this is Golden Epitaph, "a sword
made to commemorate the death of Godwyn the
Golden, first of the demigods to die". It
is "Infused with the humble prayer of a young
boy", and reads "O brother, lord brother,
please die a true death."
Clearly, the young boy in question here..is
Miquella. We can infer this, because the sigil
that appears when you use this Blade's skill
is the Haligtree sigil. And once activated,
this ability, called "last rites", imbues
the sword with a holy power that prevents
Those Who Live In Death from reviving.
What's really interesting here though, is
that this weapon points towards an early kinship
between Miquella, and Godwyn. A relationship,
which might have made it all the more painful
when Godwyn's soul perished but his body remained,
spawning deathroot. This is interesting, as
it gives Miquella a legitimate emotional grievance
against Those Who Live In Death. This is almost
ironic, considering we previously established
Miquella as this character who wants all life
to flourish - but I guess that principle might
not extend to Those Who Live In Death, hey?
Miquella's relationship with Godwyn is potentially
strengthened when we consider this statue,
found in Elphael, before the Haligtree. It
depicts a larger figure, who is clearly embracing
the two empyrean twins, Miquella, and Malenia..but
then..who is this larger figure?
It could be their parent, Marika or Radagon
- but then..it doesn't have their signature
hair braid, and instead has long, wavy hair.
What's more, the statue asset is flat-chested,
which rules out Marika, at least. So, after
reading a good amount of debate online about
this, I think it's a fair conclusion to say
that this statue represents Godwyn - who himself
does seem to have long, wavy hair.
This statue being enshrined here really tells
a story. A story of two afflicted siblings
supported by their older brother, who was
the first Demigod to die. But it's not the
only statue in this location.
Far more prominent in the area, are these
statues; of two siblings left alone, after
their brother died - with one who was forced
to remain as a young child, and another who
grew - losing limbs to rot, and decay.
These statues are everywhere in the Haligtree,
and tell the sorrowful story of these two
siblings. They are an early sign of Miquella's
extreme empathy for his sister, and his desperate
attempts to give her relief from her terrifying
condition.
And so, "the young Miquella abandoned fundamentalism,
for it could do nothing to treat Malenia's
accursed rot. This was the beginning..of unalloyed
gold".
---
So what is unalloyed gold? Well, an alloy
is created when you combine metals - usually
because you want to create a stronger compound,
at the expense of its purity. So if we were
to view Marika's Golden Order as if it were
a metal, then it would definitely be an alloyed
metal. Just think of all the foreign powers
that it's absorbed in the interest of strength:
For example, Godfrey and his crucible knights
were enlisted to devastate Marika's enemies..
the ancient dragons were won over and became
a part of Leyndell's forces [Source: Gravel
Stone Seal, Malformed Dragon Set, Lightning
Spear]...even the house of the Erdtree and
the Moon were married. LiterallyAfter all,
as Miriel puts it, "all things can be conjoined"
under the Golden Order..so I think Marika
was definitely open to fusing factions and
ideologies - as long as it made her treasured
Golden Order alloy, stronger.
So hopefully now, you understand what I mean
when I say that Miquella's gold is unalloyed.
It is pure. It is untainted. It is, perhaps,
a singular ideology. And if you subscribe
to the idea that the cut content is still
representative of Miquella, then I would say
that his ideology is what I had Miquella quote
earlier - that in his new world, all things
should be allowed to flourish, whether graceful
or malign - though that is of course, cut
content, and my own speculation.
But Miquella's unalloyed gold couldn't have
just been this metaphysical concept of pure
ideology - it was a physical material as well.
For example, this is an unalloyed gold water
lily, said to be beloved by Miquella ]. This
is a bewitching branch, blessed with an incantation
of unalloyed gold Unalloyed gold decorated
the armour and shields of his soldiers, it
was inserted into their weapons - and most
importantly, perhaps, it was forged into a
set of armour for his sister, Malenia
Because remember - the whole reason Miquella
embraced unalloyed gold, was because he thought
that it could treat his sister's accursed
rot, while fundamentalism could not. And he
was right.
For Malenia's scarlet rot is no mere disease.
It's literally the divine essence of an outer
god , and Malenia is its vessel , that will
one day bloom into a true goddess
But unalloyed gold is one of the few materials
in the game, that can ward away such meddling
of the outer
gods . Personally, I think that speaks to
the purity of Miquella's unalloyed gold ideology
- but if that's not enough reason for you,
then Quelaag has a great video where she breaks
things down at a chemical level
At any rate, Miquella crafted needles of unalloyed
gold, which could be inserted into the tortured
flesh of one afflicted by rot to alleviate
their suffering, and forestall its effects
And true to the needle's description, the
outer god of rot isn't the only one affected
by this - our character actually uses the
final version of this needle to subdue the
outer god of frenzy, if you decide not to
be a terrible person, and burn down the world
When we first find Miquella's Needle - it's
been broken. Snapped in half, and picked up
by a commander at the very center of the scarlet
swamp.
But once repaired, we can give the golden
needle to Millicent, proving that it does
indeed work to forestall the rotting sickness,
to remove pain, and nightmares from the afflicted.
It is, after all, lovingly crafted by Miquella
himself.
Now, let me have a look at the needle.
Hmm.
Well, well, this is a marvel indeed.
The work of a true artisan…a meticulous,
bold craftsman who grasps the essence of life.
In crafting these needles, and pursuing unalloyed
gold, Miquella is attempting to save his sister
from her affliction. It seems like an objectively
good deed - which is a rare sight, in Elden
Ring. Especially for a demigod, whose strengths
have been known to tip them towards madness
So it's no wonder that Malenia venerated her
brother. She is a character of undefeated
prowess , an empyrean, no less - and yet she
dedicated her blade to Miquella, and Miquella
alone. For she believes that "He possesses
the wisdom, the allure, of a god" and that
"he is the most fearsome Empyrean of all"
The story of their bond and duty to one another
is legendary - something that becomes quite
clear when we explore Miquella's Haligtree,
and see these statues depicting their embrace,
all around. If you were one of the many defiled
outcasts in Elden Ring, you too might have
felt inspired by this story..and might have
felt inclined to earn Miquella's favor and
make the long pilgrimage towards salvation.
Towards the distant, divine Haligtree, and
its brace, that was Miquella's domain.
---
Miquella of the Haligtree
So first, what even is the Haligtree? Well,
there is good evidence that it's a sort of
Erdtree. For one, Erdtree Avatars have clearly
emerged from it, which they only do in order
to protect the Erdtree's own offspring . And
then there's the Haligtree Knight Armor, which
confirms that "the Haligtree ultimately failed
to grow into an Erdtree"
And this made me wonder..when exactly was
the Haligtree planted, then? Was it planted
before, or after the shattering of the Elden
Ring?
Because when the Elden Ring was shattered,
Golden Seeds "flew from the Erdtree, scattering
across the various lands, as if life itself
knew that its end had come". These seeds create
these little illusory trees, and likely spawned
the Minor Erdtrees, so I feel like it's a
fair assumption that Miquella might have planted
the Haligtree from an Erdtree Seed. And if
that was indeed the case, then it should have
happened after the shattering - for before
that, the Erdtree was considered "perfect
and eternal", and it wasn't even believed
that Erdtree seeds could exist
On the flip side, the Golden Epitaph sword
we mentioned earlier likely existed before
the Shattering, as it was created to commemorate
Godwyn's death. And this sword displays the
haligtree sigil when its weapon art is activated,
so..one could infer that the Haligtree must
have existed at this point too. So I guess
it's always possible that Miquella somehow
procured an Erdtree Seed before the shattering,
or simply grew it from his own being, as a
scion of the Golden Bough
Whatever the case, Miquella clearly decided
that growing such a tree was important, and
even went so far as to water it with his own
blood This confirms..that the Erdtree is indeed
a blood sucking parasite. Just kidding. Kind
of. You have to admit though, It is pretty
disturbing that an Erdtree could flourish
in such a manner.
But this does lead us to the final question
which is - why was the Haligtree planted?
What is the point of it?
And at the end of the, the main reason is
always going to be because it is like the
Erdtree. I did just spend a few minutes comparing
them, after all. The Erdtree is this enormous
icon of power and faith in the Lands Between,
so evoking that and inspiring worship is clearly
a valuable thing
But the Erdtree was only really of an icon
of faith in its later years . Before that,
it was a symbol of abundance, with light as
warm as the gentle sun, gradually healing
all those who bathed in its rays . But perhaps
most importantly, it would drip sacred dew.
Sap, or tears, that could bestow blessings
, form crystal tears, and even be embedded
into talismans . Naturally, this was an extremely
value symbol for Miquella to evoke, since
he is himself associated with dew, and abundance.
And his Haligtree did drip with dew. The greenish
amber of the Haligtree can even be seen in
cut content items, which I speculate is mingled
with a bit of Miquella's own blood. That signature
green hue of haligtree amber is also seen
in the Haligtree Knight's Sword, which was
modeled after the Carian Knights' own swords,
except it was embedded with amber instead
of glintstone
But what else does the Haligtree add in terms
of value? Well, the Haligtree itself is something
of a vessel, fit for a god. Miquella plants
himself inside it. Malenia returns home to
it. And speaking of it being a home, many
other creatures have made their home within
the tree..and within the brace that supports
it.
And I guess you could argue that the Haligtree
might also be a sort of tool, to be used.
After all, Marika puts the Erdtree to use
in such a way, using its roots to absorb people
after their death, and perhaps even its branches
to rebirth life. And then the Erdtree is later
used as a prison, with thorns that are almost
entirely impenetrable. But I don't think Miquella
planned to use the Haligtree in such a way.
Perhaps the biggest difference between the
Haligtree and the Erdtree, is that the Haligtree
was built in a largely inhospitable region.
It is extremely difficult to reach, and unlike
the Erdtree, it might not really be designed
for the benefit of the vast majority of the
world. As it stands, the Haligtree strikes
me as being more like the Painted World from
Dark Souls - a place for the outcasts, the
heretical, and the malign. Not to mention
the low, and the meek, who are specifically
named out in the description of the Sacred
Crown Helm [Source: Sacred Crown Helm].
While many of the scarlet-rot afflicted seem
to be here because of the eventual decay of
the Haligtree, I think there are a number
of refugees already here - namely,
the misbegotten ... the crystalian ... these
astray mages of Raya Lucaria, and of course,
Loretta, who deemed this place to be a great
haven for the despised albinaurics
The second generation albinaurics even carry
a weapon called the "Ivory Sickle", which
reads "These weapons are evidence of their
dedication to the Haligtree, despite never
having entered its presence." And yet, we
don't find a single albinauric within the
Haligtree [NOTE: Unless you count Loretta].
Maybe they have yet to make the trip.
It makes sense that the first generation of
albinaurics not to be here, though. Even Albus
cites their faded legs as the reason for that
. And yet, we find them defending Miquella
and his Haligtree all the same - at the Ordina
Liturgical Town, which takes us to the Haligtree
via a puzzle within an Evergaol. The word
"Liturgical" means "relating to public worship",
and the town is fittingly filled with many
statues of Miquella alone - cradling what
might have become the Haligtree, but back
when it was a sapling.
I also find it interesting that the Haligtree
is never called out as competing with the
Erdtree, or for housing these undesirables.
Perhaps the House of the Erdtree was happy
to see ungraceful folk leave, perhaps the
Haligtree was extremely well-hidden from everyone,
or perhaps Miquella could simply get away
with it, because he was beloved by all.
The Bewitching Branch is an item that you
can create from Miquella's Lillies, and is
"blessed with an incantation of unalloyed
gold", and reads "The Empyrean Miquella is
loved by many people. Indeed, he has learned
very well how to compel such affection.".
And that second part, that says he has learned
well how to compel affection - to me, that's
saying that Miquella is very good at knowing
how to inspire others' affection to his own
advantage.
And nowhere is this more clear...than at Castle
Sol.
---
Lord Miquella of the Eclipse
This is the Haligtree Secret Medallion. It's
furnished with that signature green amber,
and features the Haligtree in the background,
for it allows you to access a secret, lower
level of the Grand Lift of Rold, and progress
through the consecrated snowfields to this
sacred place.
Having both halves of this secret medallion
is therefore extremely desirable. For the
medallion has another name, as "Miquella's
Favor".
Miquella's favour can be yours…
Slaughter, slaughter, slaughter... The all-hearing
slaughtered, but alas, it was for naught.
But all you need do, is snatch it from the
big pot.
Gideon is "the all-hearing" in this dialogue,
and slaughtered an entire village just for
one half, but did not find it in Albus' possession.
But you can.
And the other half? It's at Castle Sol, right
before a nameless phantom..who says this:
Lord Miquella, forgive me.
The sun has not been swallowed.
Our prayers were lacking.
Your comrade remains soulless...
I will never set my eyes upon it now...
Your divine Haligtree...
So.. this phantom seemingly has one half of
the medallion, and yet he laments that he
will now never set eyes upon the Haligtree.
To me, this suggests that Miquella might have
been withholding the second half of the medallion
from him, or that this phantom believed that
he could solicit the second half from Miquella
and make it to the Haligtree - if he achieved
his goal here at Castle Sol.
..but what exactly was supposed to happen
here at Castle Sol? What does it mean when
the phantom says "the sun has not been swallowed.
Our prayers were lacking. Your comrade remains
soulless"?
It means that the residents of Castle Sol,
and Miquella, were attempting to restore the
dead soul of Godwyn the Golden.
And just to refresh your memory: when a fragment
of the rune of death was used to kill Godwyn,
it was also being used at the exact same time,
to kill Ranni. So since they perished at the
same time, Ranni lost her body, and Miquella's
demigod brother Godwyn perished in soul alone.
And despite this death seeming so final, Miquella
clearly believes that some sort of ritual,
performed here, could restore the soul of
his comrade.
Ohh great sun! Frigid sun of Sol!
Surrender yourself to the eclipse!
Grant life to the soulless bones!
The question is...how?
So at Castle Sol, we find the Eclipse shotel,
which reads "Storied sword and treasure of
Castle Sol that depicts an eclipsed sun drained
of color. In Sol, the sight of an eclipse
inspires a dreadful awe, preventing an onlooker
from averting his gaze". The most important
part of this description though, is the part
that says it's the "storied sword" of Castle
Sol, as this proves that the veneration of
the eclipse here, goes back a long way.
But what does an eclipse represent? So according
to the Eclipse Crest shields, "The eclipsed
sun, drained of color, is the protective star
of soulless demigods", and "the sun in eclipse
is said to be the symbol of the Wandering
Mausoleum where the soulless demigods slumber".
Note that it says "demigods", plural here.
This could be because the wandering mausoleums
come to house many demigods from a gameplay
point of view, or it even be slightly lost
in translation, as the Japanese version of
the description does not specify whether it's
demigods, singular or plural. So I actually
think the slumbering demigod in question,
is Godwyn - he is the only real candidate
for a comrade of Miquella who has lost his
soul, after all. And as we established earlier,
Miquella had an affection for Godwyn, and
lamented his inability to die a true death
[Source: Golden Epitaph]. So basically, I
think the wandering mausoleums became necessary
when Godwyn died - as he was the first Demigod
to die..so the mausoleums were intended to
be a resting place for him, but also for any
future demigods, as their deaths suddenly
became possible, with the theft of Destined
Death.
The Mausoleum Knights themselves are these
headless soldiers who beheaded themselves,
willingly following their master into death
. As such, they became these headless spirits,
tied to the land so that they might defend
the walking mausoleums.
They also carry eclipse-crested shields, and
the eclipse is said to "aid the mausoleum
knights by keeping destined death at bay"
. It is their symbol, and by keeping destined
death at bay, maybe it is helping to keep
their souls tied to the land?
We could speculate for a long time on how
the eclipse has this power. You could even
argue that this "protective star", is a sort
of outer god. It's simpler though, to just
trust that Miquella knew what he was doing
with the eclipse at Castle Sol, where he wanted
to block out the sun, and restore Godwyn's
soul.
All that said, it's very important to remember:
that this ritual failed. According to this
phantom, the "sun was not swallowed", and
so, the star of the eclipse did not listen
to their prayers, and appear.
But it's fascinating to learn that such a
thing might even be possible. That Godwyn,
whose soul seems to be as dead as Ranni's
body..might actually not be?
So if his soul is somewhere, where has it
fled to?
A part of me wonders, if his soul is lost
somewhere...perhaps, within a dream.
One theory I did come up with regarding the
eclipse, is that it might be able to bring
Godwyn's soul back, by bringing about a sort
of artificial dusk. Those Who Live in Death
are called the "duskborn", after all . There
is an association between night, and death,
to be sure.
And there is also an association between death,
and sleep. For example, when you pursue Fia's
questline, you use her as a medium to enter
Godwyn's "deathbed dream", which is an entire
dreamscape where the dragon Fortissax is futilely
fighting against the death in his companion.
And then there's Rogier, who speaks this line
of dialogue, as he is on the precipice of
succumbing to deathroot,
Hmm. Maybe I should tell you.
Lately, I feel I'm on the precipice...
Of falling into a deep...fathomless slumber.
Later, Rogier does fight you, defending Fia
as one of her champions. So in conclusion:
a realm of death does seem accessible through
dream.
And this is the perfect time to mention..
that Miquella has an alter-ego. "Some say
she is a comely young girl, others are sure
he is a boy" . This is where we must talk
about the enigmatic figure named St Trina.
---
Miquella of the Haligtree (glitch effect)
St. Trina of the Cradlesong
Perhaps the biggest in-game clue about St
Trina's true identity is Trina's Lily, which
bears an undeniable resemblance to Miquella's
lily of unalloyed gold.
Its description reads "A symbol of faith in
St Trina. Dulls the senses, preventing agitation".
Naturally, it can be used to craft a bunch
of sleep-afflicting items, like St Trina's
Arrow, which states that "The sweet oblivion
of sleep can become quite the habit", and
tells of the priests of St. Trina, who "use
these arrows to spread their teachings". Though
the Japanese description seems to specify
that these were more of a tool for their rituals.
So it's largely left to your imagination as
to what rituals these priests might have been
performing - though I will mention that..it
seems St Trina might actually be able to be
found somewhere, within sleep. This is suggested
by Fevor's Cookbook, which reads "A record
of crafting techniques left by a man who was
utterly captivated by St. Trina. He continued
the search for her in his slumber."
What's not left to your imagination, is St
Trina's appearance. While their child form
seems to be engraved upon the hilt of St Trina's
sword , their feminine adult form is actually
showed upon St Trina's torch, and even called
out by the torches description, which reads
"The carvings depict St Trina, but in adult
form, somewhat unnervingly" . The carving
is indeed unnerving, and it is certainly strange,
considering Miquella is supposed to be eternally
a child. It raises the question - what has
to happen for Miquella to grow up into this?
And why is this bizarre creature, the adult
form he takes?
Another question worth asking I think, is
whether Miquella even has total control of
St. Trina. What if he's in a similar situation
to Marika Radagon, where their alter-ego is
an opposite, of sorts, and able to act almost
as if they have their own free will?
Though while this is certainly a bit of a
disturbing view of what St Trina could be
- we do have cut content that does reassure
me that their alter-ego is still a benevolent
person. This cut content was first showcased
by Sekiro Dubi, and is TRULY ancient - existing
in one of the oldest versions of the game
that we know about.
Here, we can learn about St Trina's Crystal
Ball, which reads:
"A crystal ball full of mist. Symbol of St
Trina of the Cradlesong.
Copies dream mist from a sleeping being.
Dream mist was once used as an ingredient
in rare and potent physicks.
May the quietude of slumber come to all and
sundry, even to those whose red eyes burn
with the flames of frenzy."
This reveals that this cut version of St Trina
once even had sympathy for those afflicted
by the Flame of Frenzy. They even went so
far as to teach the merchants their songs.
The cursed flame burns inside our eyelids.
Corroding the lines that separate us. That's
what the instrument is for. The tambre of
its song calms the flame, however slightly.
Caressing, gently, so that we don't blend
together. Our song derives from an old lullaby.
Sung for us, long ago, deep inside our tomb.
But whoever it was sings no longer. Its melody
allowed us to sleep, despite the cursed flame.
This description of Miquella's songs as a
lullaby is reflected by the modern-day Sleep
Pot description, which reads "Like a lullaby,
or a quagmire, its light-purple haze irresistibly
draws its victims down into sleep. Sweet dreams"
This is the closest thing we have to dream
mist, which was an item you could once collect
from sleeping enemies. After this, you were
supposed to sell it to the merchants, who
used it to quell their flame of frenzy.
But as the merchants once said - whoever it
was that sings, now sings no longer. And this
is a detail that has remained intact even
in the final version of Elden Ring, with St
Trina's sword stating that St Trina's "appearance
was as sudden as their disappearance".
Something clearly happened to Miquella, that
prevented them from continuing their work
as St Trina. And that is what we will discuss
next.
---
Miquella's Promise
At some point, Miquella embedded himself into
the Haligtree. Why he did this is never explicitly
stated, so we kind of have to rely on the
environmental storytelling here instead.
Now, Miquella famously watered the Haligtree
with his own blood since it was a sapling,
so you could argue that he embedded himself
in it to simply feed the tree more - which
I guess is possible, since the tree does eventually
wither without Miquella inside it. But I don't
think that can be the only explanation for
why he embedded himself.
For instance - look closely at the Haligtree
roots, and you'll see the form of a treelike
woman. And where her womb should be, there's
a gap. A gap that once contained Miquella's
cucoon, cradled by the Haligtree. Now, either
Miquella was attempting to fuse into and become
this womanlike figure, who might even be the
adult form shown on St Trina's Torch...
OR there was a rebirth occuring. This is a
cucoon..within a womb, after all.
But whatever the intent here , it seems things
ended prematurely. For Miquella would eventually
be ripped out of the womb, and the Haligtree
would split and decay.
So. The Haligtree, now but a husk...I heard
speculation Miquella embedded himself in the
Haligtree...but before he could finish, someone
cut the tree open and absconded with his infant
form. Indeed, it seems those words held weight.
How vexing. That the All-knowing didn't have
the full story...
And so, when we arrive at the Haligtree, and
the town of Elphael that is built into the
brace that supports it - the music hits extremely
hard. This place is just so sorrowful.
For the Haligtree, and Miquella's Lillies,
are wilting - and all who live there are hoping
- praying for their lord to return.
I love the little detail of the guards looking
outwards, and sitting dejectedly. To make
matters worse for them, it was here that they
realised that the sacred light inside them
would explode upon their imminent deaths.
And yet in spite of this, their spirit ashes
show their faith, and state "May the flash
of our deaths guide Miquella's return"
And Malenia is here too. Holding to the husk
of Miquella. Dreaming. Waiting for Miquella
to return, and believing full well that he
will.
Corpse after corpse, left in my wake...
As I awaited... his return.
Malenia's Set reveals that she believes her
brother will keep his promise..so what was
that promise, I wonder? Was it merely to return,
or something more? How much does Malenia know?
Why did she fight Radahn? We'll have to talk
about all that, and more, in another video.
But not all here are hopeless. There's this
one phantom in the consecrated snowfields
who has clearly puzzled out who took Miquella,
and is pointed towards the Omen himself.
Give him back! Give Lord Miquella back! Mohg,
you rotten omen!
Indeed, it was the demigod Mohg who somehow
broke into the Haligtree, and absconded with
Miquella's infant form. And it's with him
this story ends. Or perhaps, it's where this
story truly begins.
---
Mohg's Promise
So if you're not familiar, Mohg is the omen
son of Godfrey and Marika. Being an omen of
royalty , he was born into a wretched mire
of filth in the subterranean shunning grounds
below the capital - but unlike his brother
Morgott who reviled his accursed blood - Mohg
revelled in it
It was because of this accursed blood that
he chanced a meeting with an outer god, called
the "Mother of Truth" . And as Mohg "stood
before her, deep underground, his accursed
blood erupted with fire, and he was truly
besotted with the defilement that he was born
into"
Mohg is just one of many characters who discovers
a new identity in the ways that they have
been discarded by the world. And how could
he not? For his defilement was validated by
nothing less than an outer god.
And as always, we know very little about this
outer god. We know she is called the "mother
of truth", and the "formless mother". We know
that she "desires wounds", and "bestows power
upon accursed blood". Her followers can thrust
their arms into her body to scatter bloodflame,
and share in the Lord of Blood's power to
send bloodflies before them.
But the one thing that all outer gods seem
to have in common, is that they require vessels
to move through. So in this case, the Formless
Mother's vessel was Mohg. For example, the
sacred spear he wields is a weapon, but also
an instrument of communion, and Mohg may well
be doing her bidding with his actions
These actions included him starting a new
dynasty, called Mohgwyn, deep below the earth,
in the grounds of these ancient, dynastic
remains. This is a secret place. Difficult
to reach - and it was here that Mohg brought
the infant Miquella, torn as he was from his
cocoon. I mean, that's how we see him in the
opening cutscene - but in-game Miquella seems
to be back within a new cocoon here. You can
even see it sat upon a giant pelvic bone,
which seems to be a reference to the womb
of the Haligtree woman that he was literally
ripped from [CREDIT: Quelaag].
From the Remembrance of the Blood Lord, we
learn of Mohg's intent here. He wished to
"raise Miquella to full godhood" and "become
his consort, taking the role of monarch".
To this end, Mohg has begun soliciting blood
offerings to Miquella. That certainly explains
the state of the many who reside here... According
to the Lord of Blood's exultation talisman,
he proclaimed "Render up your offerings of
blood to your Lord. Drench my consort's chamber.
Slake his cocoon's thirst. His awakening shall
herald the dawn of our dynasty"
And then, to return to Mohg's Remembrance,
it's stated that "no matter how much of his
bloody bedchamber Mohg tried to share, he
received no response from the young Empyrean".
So maybe nothing will happen. Or maybe, according
to the Pureblood Knight's Medal "It is not
yet time. For For Mohg yet slumbers beside
the Divinity. Be Patient. The new dynasty
is nigh".
What do you think? I mean, it's hard to know.
Even Gideon has no clue.
Well I wonder what comes next...If he continues
his slumber within the cocoon, all would be
well. But perhaps it would be safer to destroy
it. Miquella is the one thing that remains
a mystery to me...
But something does seem to be happening to
Miquella, in there. He has clearly grown,
since being taken - so maybe his adult form
is manifesting...
And personally, this all reminds me a lot
of Berserk. Spoiler warning - but there's
this moment at the very end of the first chapter,
where Griffith betrays his companions in this
sacrificial ceremony of carnage and bloodshed,
in order to be inaugurated and reborn as a
god.
This..really reminds me of that. It also reminds
me of a scene with Griffith where he allows
himself to be abused, in order to get what
he wants.
So..I wonder, what if this was also what Miquella
wanted? We know that he is extremely proficient
at compelling others to love him, and Mohg
is clearly enraptured. We know that he is
an empyrean prodigy, and we know that his
sister, who knows him best, has total faith
that he will return.
Or maybe maybe Miquella didn't predict this
at all, and is being completely taken advantage
of.
Or maybe he did intend to be taken, but is
going to get more than he bargained for with
the Mother of Truth.
Or maybe Miquella's fate is long gone. After
all, in a place called Miquella's Hideaway
in Altus Plateau, we can loot the Amber Starlight,
which Seluvis mentions is the very fate of
a demigod.
Or maybe the cut content is very much removed
from the game because it doesn't fit the developers
intent for Miquella. I hope you all bear in
mind that that is a possibility, as I would
hate to promote ideas that are against the
developer's new vision for this character.
But it's definitely a possibility, I think,
that we could one day enter the dream of this
slumbering demigod. After all, once, there
was a cut character called Rhico, who was
supposed to say the following, standing before
Miquella's cocoon at Mohgwyn Palace
"Finally, I have found it..... St. Trina's,
no, Lord Miquella's cadaver... Such that I
may aid you, O Lord... So please, I hope you
welcome your humble servant Rhico... Into
your dream, the world of your heart......
Indeed, I beg you grant my wish, that when
you transcend from empyrean to god, allow
me a place by your side....."
Plus if we do get DLC, it's going to need
a new Great Rune to acquire, right? That's
a big gameplay mechanic in Elden Ring. And
the only other ones that we know exist are
Ranni's, which she cast aside, and Miquella's,
which presumably still resides with him
So hopefully we get some DLC to answer these
questions. Or, more likely, DLC will give
us more questions than we started with. That's
always how it seems to go. I bet they'll throw
us some good curveballs, as they always do.
But regardless, it's always a ton of fun to
specualte with you all. So if you're still
listening - thank you for giving me your time
today..and subscribe for more! See you next
time.
---